io sto rivolgendo appreso mio obiettivo
prendi 16 sotto è un solo come sapone
per le mani ricettava giustino internati
solide star is born simic e super pazzo
compiuti anche povero perché tra fare
allora perché sa su instagram di dirmi
ti rompi lì quindi penitenze diciamo
obblighi slime e mi avete scritto le
cose più assurde vabbè fatti sono
cattivi nei capelli
tutte lo slam ad ospitare come di
strenne bruscino così assurda che
risulta comunque ne ho selezionato
alcuni e andrò a fare questi umbri che
impenitente questa è la prima cosa che
faccio un video pubblichi slime lasciato
in bella ex se volete che abbia un altro
vedremo al fine di questo video senso
pratico e un altro in base ai numeri tra
quelli quindi iniziamo subito
il primo penitenza allora prima pendenza
o pubblico che chiamare mingo tutti
l'indie scrive fai uno slide con la neve
non ti limita allora questo non è troppo
cattivo e crudele come obbligo penitenza
per gli effetti non ho mai provato pure
con simon sulla neve non diluita eccola
qua e sono molto curioso di vedere cosa
succede quindi dobbiamo farlo insieme a
quanto già tante cose da mettere la
colla portato finito la con la
trasparenza e quindi non posso dare
l'acqua trasparente tra l'altro un po
bagnata questa ciotola spero che non
faccia gonfiare la neve vabbè vediamo
comunque ho detto subito sì
ci ha messo un sacco in genere
quest'anno quando aggiungi l'acqua
diventa
tutti esigo troppe tifosi volte diventa
enorme
comunque io non c'entro niente
ecco come lo vediamo cosa mettere java
[Musica]
perché diventa neve quindi la mischia e
botta buche strano
ma non si è gonfiata per si sta
solidificando sembra se poi si può
abbozzare la stracciatella
[Musica]
oddio passeggiato edificato senza che
strada senza tiratore che strano senso
attivatore che cosa si parla
[Musica]
più persone ma c'è solidissimo che
strano no non c'è bisogno di altro
fattore perché non molto in questi non
saprei come descriverlo cosa ne pensate
voi di questo sliven svezia attivatore a
solida scrivetemi che i commenti che
voto date a questo coso da 1 a 10
quindi questo è il primo obbligo ho
fatto lo slide con la neve finta non
diluita ed è uscita questa costa a cosa
ne pensate win o un ace scritto di
commenti
ora passiamo al prossimo
mi spiace preferito quello che ti senti
veramente malefici questo google ha
scritto anna rita ricco tete malefici
veramente io sono andata a caccia di mix
live e ho ritrovato questo che faccio da
poco in quelle date più bello allora il
fresco messo buy
centro possibile meglio quindi ci sono
vari strati e borico lo regge
chiediamolo fuori vediamo un po a
mariscal imparate durante tutto popoli
allora secondo questa stanza ci sono
tipo 40 gradi tutti gli scambi si stanno
sciogliendo maledizione
guardate che quello alle sfumature non
sono del tutto dentro colore perché
disciolto praticamente a parte che
interessano tutti ma le palline che le
perline anche ischia ci riesce ad
indovinare velocemente
sicuramente i ponti lavorate capito da
allora non è quello che una maglia
perché se avete visto il video in cui
invitare facciamo la facciamo male
quello con l'angelo che un tutto tutta
insieme la busta abbiamo buttato nel
cestino abbiamo buttato là caldo abbiamo
buttato tutto perché non vi dico che
onore faceva di tutta la calza nera
allucinante
quello lo abbiamo visto mutare perché la
liquido va bene comunque
però ne è rimasto un altro
ricordate il quale tra loro ma sembra
carino guerra sembra normale ma ancorate
bene qua sotto
penso che questo sia un po perché
comunque si cereali come la dentro
confessore n
questo è quello che ho fatto io c'era la
senape e ketchup
grazie quindi addio lime e quello che
schifo
[Musica]
quando che stava solo strato con l'altro
che pur ta ecco fatto schifo toccarlo
sono mangiati perché vive evidente che
se tutta la bomba chiediamo e passiamo
al prossimo o pubblico allora pronti co
op un pezzetto anche falsi intestati cat
inizia con la tata steel 2 3 ma allora
parte a ultime usano sempre la parte le
mani e voi
marty 05 mi scrive ben 16 sciolto e
usano come sapone per le mani seriamente
questo 7 creativi poi altri di voi mi
scriveva queste cose tremonti meglio
berti un per i tabù qua o mostrare il
super sciolto non so se ve lo ricordate
realtà quasi tutti i miei stanno
sciogliendo su quel caso che c'è ma così
in particolare aveva più sotto degli
altri il problema è allora non vado a
farlo nel lavandino perché non voglio
che si incardina fantino e non voglio
inquinare soprattutto non vado a fare
una bambina ho la faccia questo il
tavolo ma niente per qualche strana
ripiego di carreggiata
guardo sempre le cose a cedere ma le
catene come cassano si è creato tipo una
corta se creativo una pellicola sopra
brand e alta dentro è sciolto e ti amo
ecco cos'è per toglierlo metto solo la
delta fare niente
[Musica]
oddio se sembra che non sia mai stato
formato questo slime è fortissimo ho
perso tutto l'attivatore detto questo
caso sia sciolto per il caldo e freddo
come la possibile non ha un bellissimo
aspetto però quindi con le palline
dentro bellissimo siete contenti adesso
quindi ho fatto anche quest'altro
obbligo non so come farà un altro dietro
tale mani acqua vediamo quale l'altro
pubblicati su posso farlo solo con una
mano perchè mi libro che c'e nessuno
quelle verificate un altro obbligo e
immergi un alone di uno slam per
sacrificare un alone e penso che nel
marcelo proprio in questo perché
guardate quanto spazio c'è e questo
perché si cosa non sostenuti che non
puoi affrontarla visto quanto è amici
koso ma allora mi spiace ma non di armi
trenta lingue vittima da sacrificare
emergere brookline e anche vestita forti
cioè alla maglia sopra vedete però
l'unica porta bene per tutti matti non
so perché ma anche simbolo da sta pian
piano la invertiamo tutta è comunque
riuscito a superarlo aiuto cipe
pressione andata non si vede per niente
è scomparso è stata risucchiata
completamente questo vino è diventato un
film horror che piace
infatti mi ami ma recuperano con questa
mano oddio riemergendo ha preso avvio da
rim per gesù non sono possibili
fu però possibile passo vita da te non
riesce a passare attraverso lo strato di
sliven aiutiamola qualsiasi appoggio ma
impressione contante sono a caso slime
anche dentro la loro messa di si guarda
la bocca piena
grazie perché ho un quanto fa buddisti
laghi finisce qua scritto sopra piazza
adesso comunque rimettiamo anzi no
[Musica]
buddista un titolo che nasce dalle due
bombe raramente tra questa quindi la
rimangiamo dentro blasi e le scrive
arrabbiati e picchia mousseline voi
sapete che il comprabile sta succendo
sapete darmi slate page ma questa volta
tipo picchiarono slime in più aggiunge
perché è riuscito con una possibilità ma
ora andiamo a
chiare perché gelosa lo slime esce con
un altro slime peso lui è uscito con la
plastilina
io penso di circa server capito così
allora certo questo come vittima in
questo ma per fortuna non si è sciolto
questa tesi dire che ci sta perché ma
per l'uso come la un bicchiere di tipo
cattivo saiwa 12 con la pratica comunque
non lo so ma è divertente verso con un
sì di slide sarebbe ancorché di marte
anche la dieta sembrò
un buon senso perché sembra belve axidie
lanciato cattivo mattina a questo punto
prossimo in testa allora rossella 01 07
mi disse cerca di fare una bolla furious
line un interessante su un piede
seriamente perché sto farmaco ho visto
dei video in cui patrimonio che fosse
contrario sbaglia da destinare però e
poi
l'hanno suggerito che quello che volete
allora non s
prova a tagliare un pezzo è fatto in
quella zona
qua risalenti sta liberando da sola
sto liberando per viva non è più amici
cosa che è strano perché si incontra
destro con l'area del significato che
belle sono libera
e allora poi non lo so proviamo c'erano
quasi me lo devi prendere tutto in mano
per poi buttarlo per incamerare aria
[Musica]
veloce guardi va bene facciamo che io
credo di una folla
ora proviamo un piede ok ragazzo
preparato lo stesso pensi
spero che possono uscire la polla i
tentativi che proviamo e riproviamo si
possono considerare pole per te quella
prima ne rimane faccia un po la prossima
volta
[Applauso]
si è quindi fare lo stesso graffiate
parlato c'è un porta proviamo a
schiacciarle non scoppiano ma vabbè con
sushi la passiamo all'ultimo mente
proprio per secchia la peggiore di tutte
belle aveva subito
marty 03 ci scrive mezzi lo slime su una
maglietta che ti piacevo l'utilizzo di
reti contro il prezzo
mi piace rossi mi piace su 60
sacrificarla correnti tutto lo slime
completo questi cappelli casa mai
successa tanta miseria
io non so se poi dovrò buttare la
maglietta perché non si stacca allora
allargato un po così si sta qui è meglio
[Musica]
chi sta incontrando dire in costume da
bagno
oddio che non è capito bene il volto
quindi prendete lo conoscevo ma ero mai
perdere qualcuno si incolla stranamente
incollato non penso proprio che
recupererò la maglietta dopo di mobilità
da questo outfit nuova edizione di
superficie con perline brillantini
nanetti
non so perché ma lo stand e spregio non
so come sia possibile che gli è sempre
mancato freddi però si sciolgono quindi
ci sarà dopo di freschezza
in tutto questo caso comunque ora
provate a troviamo possa salvare questo
bellissimo maglietta sempre mettiamo un
po allora quale in alcuni punti rimasti
non ci posso credere
no non proprio
[Musica]
io però qua mi sembra più incollata
pensavo peggio
quindi penso che ogni caso la potrebbe
usarla però non penso che la maggior
parte dell'amante sarebbe stato
poi alcuni invece sono infiltrati titolo
quindi incredibile come stata facilmente
sarebbe fantastico se anche dai capelli
stesse così ma non è così perché abbiamo
fatto per ora è riemerso vuole
riprendere vita poveretta mi fa tanto
bene abbiamo un ct che ha subito lo
staff attimo che propone scansarle va a
testa bassa la stretta alla bocca e ti
amo c'è paura non solo la luz long sopra
perso la testa per lo slime con le major
comunque guardate al line in bocca per
non è se quindi persone intanto se
volete un altro video di slime obi
intense lasciato un bel laiche di cimino
vice andrò a farmi un altro come sempre
potete seguirmi su instagram è il nome è
un'intesa doris così potrà consigliarvi
3 per i tende e pubblici e ora vi lascio
fa 4 cartelline su cui potete cliccare
per vedere i miei consumi perché vedere
del challenge di video divertenti video
sul pride cliccate su quello che
preferite e buona visione
altro ko